yes well I spiders too very felled day
for me I'm a very happy man to have been
offered the chance to merge in my
country I'm looking forward enormously
to the task ahead everyone knows it's
not an easy one but I'm also hoping that
everybody fans supporters everybody
within the country will get behind the
team because it's the team that counts
it's the team which will witness matches
and what I would do is I'll do my best
to make sure the team is as well
prepared as possible for the toss of my
head I'm grateful for the chance to be
the manager of England and I'll be
looking for - well yeah it's gonna be
difficult of course but hopefully I've
got a lot of time on my hands - to think
about it and to make the decisions that
are necessary obviously I've been
working the country now for the last
five years so all of the players are I'm
pretty well known to me even though I
haven't worked with that many of them
and it's gonna be very important after
this press conference to get straight
down to the task really making certain
the when the time comes to announce the
squad which we are like to put back as a
matter of fact until after the last game
of the season that I've done as much
research as I can and spoken to as many
players as I possibly can
well I think the important thing of the
moment is for me to speak to as many
players as possible of course join a
meal as respective members of the team
are gonna be - I do need to speak to but
I couldn't answer your question for this
moment in time sorry not before I've had
a chance to hopefully sit down with them
but if I can't sit down with them reach
them on the telephone